[Music]
as you see in daily life you're pushing
a box your weight which is a force
acting downwards hammering a big nail
into the ground all these forces if you
notice are acting perpendicular to the
surface a force exerted by an object
perpendicular to the surface is given a
special name
it's called thrust it's the total force
acting perpendicular to the surface what
will be the unit of thrust in the SI
system can you get you should have got
this one trust is nothing but force so
the SI unit of thrust will be the same
as that of force Newton the SI unit of
thrust is Newton what's pressure now I
don't want the definition or the formula
I want you to understand it let me give
you a couple of examples take a pencil
and keep it between your thumb and index
finger with the tip touching the index
finger and the other end touching the
thumb now apply equal force from both
ends towards the pencil for a few
seconds release the pencil and observe
the two fingers to be precise observe
the depression you see in the fingers
you notice that the depression in your
index finger is much more as compared to
the depression in your thumb why does
that happen before we answer that let me
give you a second situation when you
stand on loose and you see that your
feet go deep into the sand now if you
lie down on the sand will you go just as
deep into the sand no you won't but if
the force exerted in both the cases is
the weight of your body then why is the
depth in the first case more that's
where the concept of pressure comes in
pressure is nothing but the force per
unit area if we're talking about trust
it would be trust per unit area if the
trust is constant and the area is more
then the press
we'll be later and if the area is less
then the pressure will be more pressure
is inversely proportional to the area on
which the thrust is applied now we can
understand the two situations in terms
of this formula what happened in the
first situation as we apply an equal
force from both ends the last for the
Newton's third law the pencil will also
apply an equal and opposite force on the
fingers at the depression was more on
the index finger that's because the area
on which the tip of the pencil applies a
force on is lesser as compared to the
area on which the other end of the
pencil applies a force on as the area is
lesser the pressure is more and that's
why the depression is more can you
understand the second situation using
this concept in the second situation the
area on which your feed life is letter
as compared to the area on which your
entire body lies and that's why the
pressure is more when your feet are on
the sand as compared to when your entire
body lies on the sand which explains why
the depth here is more what is the SI
unit of pressure as its force over area
it would be mutant per meter squared
this is the SI unit of pressure and this
is also called as Pascal one Pascal is
one Newton over one meter squared this
would be named after a famous scientist
called Blaine Pascal who had conducted
extensive studies in this area of
science let's quickly recap what we
learned what thrust it's the total force
acting perpendicular to the surface and
what's pressure it's the trust per unit
area if the same amount of thrust is
applied on a lesser area then the
pressure will be more
[Music]
you